Joan we had a question come in from Brad
Hodges and his twitter handle is at got
carted hi Brad so he says what
strategies can be used to keep a hidden
opponent concealed for a season without
the reveal seeming like gee it's an
interesting question because this hidden
opponent is a very important character
in any form of storytelling now with TV
would get an interesting problem which
is that when we have a hidden opponent
in film it's only going to cover about
two hours to have sustained a hidden
opponent in a television show it would
almost by 2 and sustain that over an
entire season the show would almost
necessarily be a serial type of show and
what what's happening is there's a great
value to the hidden upon because we get
a big reveal when we find out that this
person that we thought was a friend of
the hero is actually an enemy but that's
one pop and so if you're trying to
sustain that over an entire season the
cost is tremendous because that means
that the function of that character is
reduced to that one moment probably near
the end of the season when the big
revelation occurs which is why i would
suggest think very carefully about
whether you want to sustain a hidden
opponent for that long because what
you're giving up is tremendous now in
terms of how you do it don't worry about
whether the reveal will seem fake or
artificial the trick to when you reveal
that character is the motivation why
have they pretended to be a friend but a
really an enemy if you give them a
strong motivation the audience will
accept it totally
you